voodoo sharks cringey dance scenes and
that time wesley snipes actually tried
to strangle someone can movie sequels
get much worse than this
the batman franchise worked its way
through three leading men over the space
of four films in the 80s and the 90s but
it came to a screeching halt with 1997's
batman and robin which found george
clooney taking over the starring role
director joel schumacher's campy tone
had been set by batman forever as a
deliberate attempt to honor the 60s adam
west batman tv series
holy rested metal batman huh
you're grown it's all metal it's full of
holes you know but it was ratcheted up
even further with batman and robin which
felt like a huge step back after the
somewhat more serious tim burton
installments in the franchise the studio
began developing a sequel even before
batman and robin arrived in theaters but
wretched reviews and disappointing
box-office grosses put an end to those
plans before they could see the light of
day as hard as it might be to imagine
today many industry watchers at the time
predicted that batman and robin would
end batman's potential as a viable
silver screen character it would take
nearly a decade and director christopher
nolan's far grittier reinvention to
bring a rebooted caped crusader back to
the screen meanwhile the ben affleck and
robert pattinson dark knights couldn't
be any more different than schumacher's
vision and that certainly doesn't seem
like a bad lesson learned
the star trek franchise had a pretty
remarkable run at the box office firing
off 10 films in 23 years while
simultaneously ruling the syndicated
airwaves with a small army of tv shows
by the early aughts however the
franchise had arrived at an
uncomfortable crossroads the low-rated
star trek enterprise was its sole show
remaining on the air and grosses for the
films had been solid but unimpressive
since the cast of star trek the next
generation took over from the original
crew this all added up to a reduced
budget and an action-heavy approach for
2002's star trek nemesis which was not a
good fit for the more intellectual image
the series had always aspired to present
opening in a year-end blockbuster rush
that also included films from the harry
potter lord of the rings and the james
bond franchises nemesis simply couldn't
hold its own the film was all but
ignored at the box office although this
was probably a good thing considering
its disastrous reviews this
installment's crash landing was enough
to keep trek films out of theaters for
some time until jj abrams finally
rebooted the franchise in 2009
the original beverly hills cop was one
of the wildest funniest films of the 80s
capturing one of the greatest
entertainers of his generation at a time
when he felt fresh young and hungry but
the law of diminishing returns weighed
heavily on its sequels having struck
comedy gold with eddie murphy as a fish
out of water detroit cop in sunny la the
studio doubled down on action set pieces
at the expense of the sharp humor that
gave the first movie its true kick the
swollen price tag that went along with
murphy's increased celebrity status
didn't help either with 1994's beverly
hills cop 3 the franchise completely
lost its way putting murphy's detective
axel foley in the midst of a convoluted
downright dull amusement park mystery
that all the tailpipe bananas in the
world couldn't fix there have been
numerous rumors over the years
pertaining to a potential fourth film
but for now axel seems confined to desk
duty
sam raimi's spider-man movies weren't
just a commercial force in the early
2000s they were a pop culture phenomenon
long after the superman and batman films
had petered out the 2002 spider-man
movie starring tobey maguire as peter
parker earned rave reviews and a
staggering 821 million dollars at the
box office spider-man 2 was every bit as
well received upon its arrival in 2004
raking in 788 million dollars and some
equally stellar reviews and then it all
went horribly wrong 2007 spider-man 3
earned criticism for having too many
subplots too many villains and too much
of this
how's the pie
so good
still spider-man 3 outgrossed its
forerunners so in 2008 sony ordered two
additional installments in the franchise
maguire agreed to return for 50 million
dollars total for both films and big
name big ticket actors john malkovich
and anne hathaway were reportedly in
talks to join the cast but in january
2010 a couple months before filming on
spider-man 4 was scheduled to begin the
film was scrapped raymie reportedly
didn't think he had enough time to turn
out a decent movie before the may 2011
release date sony subsequently canceled
spider-man 4 entirely opting instead to
reboot the franchise in 2012.
fewer film franchises have endured a
faster fall from grace then the robocop
series the 1987 original was a critical
and commercial smash and unlike a lot of
hit films its storyline had all sorts of
obvious sequel potential star peter
weller departed after 1990's
disappointing robocop 2 some people
pointed out this wasn't that big of a
deal however since he had almost
entirely been covered by a futuristic
supersuit looking back decades later
it's clear that the best elements of
robocop were paul verhoeven through and
through and the mistakes of subsequent
robocop films weren't that they couldn't
recapture the character but that they
couldn't recapture the director even if
weller had stayed it's unlikely that
robocop 3 would have been a hit without
verhoven the studio was busy going
bankrupt during filming and the violence
was curtailed in an effort to make
things more accessible for younger fans
leaving the end result a low budget
shell of the ultra violent original
robocop 3 sat in the vault for a year
before limping into theaters in 1993 and
it'd be another 21 years before the
franchise returned with a reboot
mortal kombat was a surprise hit in 1995
raking in more than 100 million dollars
in spite of the fact that like the video
game that inspired it it was little more
than a series of fight scenes held
together by a few shreds of ludicrous
plotting it's hard to blame the studio
for trying to make the lightning strike
twice with 1997's mortal kombat
annihilation even by the original's
relaxed standards though it's a flimsy
excuse for a movie and this time
audiences agreed staying away in droves
another sequel was in the planning
stages for years but it took quite some
time for the franchise to finally rise
from the dead with 2021's mortal kombat
that movie at least turned out to be
slightly better than those original
movies slightly
you're gonna need a bigger boat
question one how do you make a sequel to
a movie about a killer shark who dies in
the final act question two why would you
even bother the answer to the second
question is obviously money but there
really isn't a good answer to the first
as a series of jaws sequels has
demonstrated over the years the studio
cranked out your basic rehash for jaws 2
then got desperate for ideas resorting
to a cheap gimmick for 1983's jaws 3d
but even that silliness pales in
comparison to jaws the revenge which
imagines a vengeful shark deliberately
picking off members of the first film's
central family hampered by low budget
effects and a script that at one point
attributed the shark's murder spree to
the work of a vengeful witch doctor the
fourth jaws was a critical and financial
disaster even in an era of constant
reboots this is one franchise that has
remained blissfully underwater
sigourney weaver's ellen ripley has
always been the cornerstone of the alien
franchise and her death at the end of
1992's alien 3 seemed to mark the end of
the series but where there's potential
to make money there's almost always a
sequel ready to be made so in 1997
weaver returned for alien resurrection
which jumped 200 years ahead of its
predecessor to bring back ripley as an
alien birthing clone audiences didn't
respond as well as they had to previous
installments perhaps best evidenced by
the fact that it debuted behind the
robin williams comedy flubber at the box
office critics were generally unkind to
what they deemed a series that had lost
its luster the studio later looted the
franchise for spare parts with the alien
vs predator movies seemingly cutting off
any possibility for another true sequel
prometheus and alien covenant gave the
franchise a semi-successful resurrection
and in 2015 it briefly looked as though
an alien 5 was ready to go with weaver
back and director neil blomkamp at the
helm but that movie was ultimately
shelved a series is currently in the
works with fargo and legion mastermind
no holly here's hoping it can deliver
some of the magic of those first two
movies
in the eyes of some henry cavill is the
best superman in the eyes of others
however christopher reeve will always
hold that title this makes it even more
of a shame that reeves portrayal of
kal-el went down in the toxic plume of
silliness known as superman 4 the quest
for peace lured back to the franchise
with the promise of a socially relevant
story reeve did his best to bring a
sense of dignity to this 1987 debacle
which pits superman against nuclear man
a solar-powered villain created by lex
luthor i want to propose a toast
to a nice guy
who's about to finish last the studio's
financial troubles hobbled the movie
throughout production forcing the
director to reuse footage and skimp on
the special effects it would take nearly
20 years before the character would
return to theaters with brian singer's
superman returns which itself was a
precursor to cavil zack snyder and
2013's man of steel
sometimes a sequel feels like a bad idea
even before the first day on set nick
cage's 2007 ghost rider was one of the
last blockbuster films he had made
before becoming a vod star in the 2010s
and although it made a decent 228
million dollars globally it's hard to
imagine anyone leaving the theater
wanting more still holding the rights to
the character in the early days of the
mcu sony greenlit ghost rider spirit of
vengeance shooting the film largely in
romania and turkey and hoping its cast
of rising stars could take it to the
next level spoiler alert
they didn't spirit of vengeance earned
about half as much as the previous ghost
rider movie and opened to even worse
reviews those factors doomed any chance
of a direct sequel as did sony who lost
the rights to the ghost rider character
in 2013. that same year cage told
collider he was no longer interested in
playing johnny blaze
after laying low for much of the 80s
michael myers returned with 1988's aptly
titled halloween 4 the return of michael
myers kicking off a new trilogy of cheap
slashers that built a ludicrous
backstory for the mute masked serial
killer in short it revolved around his
niece jaime and his unceasing need to
kill everyone who was related to him in
some way all that was retconned out of
existence for 1998's halloween h2o which
jumped back and acted as a direct sequel
to halloween 2. after h2o racked up
nearly 75 million dollars at the box
office another sequel was guaranteed
unfortunately no one bothered to show up
for halloween resurrection which added
buster rhymes to the cast and utilized a
reality tv inspired horror comedy tone
luckily having endured a few more
reboots myers is stronger than ever
these days and has long forgotten
his wayward niece
movie success can be hard to predict and
few could have guessed that a low-key
low-budget fish out of water action
comedy from australia would be the top
grossing comedy of 1986 out earned
globally only by top gun crocodile
dundee starred paul hogan as mick
crocodile dundee a rugged but immensely
charming outdoorsman from the australian
outback who finds himself dealing with a
new way of life in new york city
[Music]
that's a knife just two years later
crocodile dundee ii arrived and it
attracted almost as much box office
business as the previous movie another
sequel would have been warranted but
hogan wanted to try other things for a
while you can thank this era for flipper
after a five-year hiatus from the big
screen hogan was ready to return to what
he thought the people wanted making a
third mcdundee movie crocodile dundee in
los angeles found the character and his
son investigating a possible murder at a
movie studio it took in just 39 million
globally in the summer of 2001 and later
accrued a lowly 11 score on rotten
tomatoes
no matter how implausible it got for
john mclean to keep randomly
encountering bloodthirsty terrorists
hollywood kept churning out die hard
movies the same off-the-wall sequel itis
followed the original speed and for good
reason the hit 1994 action classic after
all was essentially die hard on a bus
but the speed franchise was ultimately
left dead in the water following the
release of speed 2 cruise control keanu
reeves decided not to reprise his role
in the movie so the sequel followed
sandra bullock's annie on a cruise with
her new cop boyfriend alex shaw
portrayed by series newcomer jason
patrick the bad guy the second time
around was a computer hacker played by
willem dafoe but neither the return of
bullock nor defoe's unhinged antics were
enough to create a need for more speed
earning a disappointing 48 million
dollars at the box office in the u.s
speed 2 was seen as one of the more
disappointing high profile releases of
the year nominated for eight razzie
awards it currently holds a shockingly
low four percent at rotten tomatoes
there will likely never be a speed three
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
crease 2 is a classic example of how not
to do a sequel gone from the original
movie word director randall kleiser
stars john travolta and olivia
newton-john and composers jim jacobs and
warren casey the one major thing that
did carry over from greece to greece to
the plot it's almost a complete rehash
except the roles are gender swapped
needless to say grease 2 which came out
four years after the original was not a
huge hit it made 15 million dollars at
the box office about 10 percent of what
greece had earned in the states alone
according to original greece cast member
dede khan who briefly appeared in the
sequel the studio's low expectations for
the first film ultimately doomed greece
too she told tv guide there was a setup
in the first film for a sequel about
summer school but paramount didn't know
greece was going to be such a success so
they passed by the time they got around
to it they couldn't get john anymore so
they came up with a new concept talk of
a third grease occasionally bubbles up
but it always fizzles out eventually
over the course of three movies the
griswolds endured a terrible road trip
to wally world a horrible trip to europe
and a horrible christmas where they
stayed at home by 1997 there was only
one place left to go
vegas
vegas
the fourth film in the vacation series
didn't score with critics or audiences
perhaps because it was the first
vacation movie not to bear the national
lampoon seal of approval or to be at
least partially scripted by john hughes
and despite being set in sin city it's
also the only installment to earn a tame
pg rating vegas vacation took in 36
million at the box office about half of
what christmas vacation had earned
sending the franchise into a long
theatrical deep freeze a few vacation
vets returned for an ill-fated
direct-to-video sequel to christmas
vacation but the family's next big
screen outing wouldn't come until 2015's
vacation original stars chevy chase and
beverly deangelo were relegated to a
cameo for this movie and neither the
reviews nor the box office were enough
to inspire the studio to do much more
with the franchise
2005 sin city was as faithful as a comic
adaptation can get utilizing an
all-digital filming technique robert
rodriguez's film version of the frank
miller series looks like a comic book in
motion perhaps owing in part to the fact
that miller himself has a co-directing
credit dazzling visuals and a noirish
plot led to critical praise and
158 million dollars worldwide making a
sequel more a matter of when than if
despite all that success the filmmakers
took their sweet time getting the next
sin city to the big screen perhaps too
long in fact sin city a dame to kill
fort limped into theaters in 2014 nine
long years after the original long after
most people had moved on by the time a
dame to kill four reached audiences its
once unique visual style had been so
thoroughly absorbed into the mainstream
that it no longer felt fresh or
innovative the movie made just 39
million dollars and suffered a critical
drubbing before it opened rodriguez and
miller said they were already talking
about a third installment but that
chatter has quieted considerably or
maybe they're just taking another decade
between sequels
marvel's fantastic four is one of the
great comic book superhero teams it took
a surprisingly long time for reed
richards and company to make their big
screen debut however and some would
argue they still have it at least not
properly say that again
it's fantastic
yes it is
tapes of a low budget never officially
released 1994 roger corman attempt
became a collector's item while a 100
million dollar fox stab in 2005 grossed
333.5 million dollars and seemed to be
headed in the right direction but the
2007 follow-up fantastic four rise of
the silver server stumbled out of the
gate and never recovered the sequel made
less money than the first movie and its
reviews weren't exactly great either in
2008 star chris evans told mtv news that
the lackluster response to the silver
surfer had effectively killed this take
on the characters he said i've heard
nothing from anyone at fox we had all
planned on doing another one but if
there were going to be a third i think a
week after the second one was released
we would have heard still though hope
lingers on for marvel's first family
here's a formula for box office success
a male character who in desperate times
must dress up in the clothes of an old
woman and then convincingly live as one
until their ruse is discovered robin
williams mrs doubtfire brought in more
than 200 million dollars while martin
lawrence's first two big mama's house
comedies earned a combined 310 million
dollars clearly lots of people found the
idea of lawrence's fbi agent going deep
undercover as a matriarchal southern
woman named big mama to be absolutely
hilarious in 2011 producers found a way
to get lawrence back in drag one more
time while simultaneously attempting to
send the big mama's house franchise in a
new direction in big mamas like father
like son lawrence's character goes
undercover with his stepson trent who
takes on the clothing and guise of a
woman named charmaine it didn't work the
third movie earned far less than its two
predecessors and scored a woeful five
percent on rotten tomatoes those figures
spelled the end for any big mama sequel
starring jackson which he probably
wouldn't want to make anyway he told
comedy hype in 2019 that movie was not
good the whole dress bit was overdone it
was hacky
meet the parents was a rare blockbuster
comedy and one that seemed to announce
ben stiller and robert de niro as the
perfect pairing audiences were left
wanting more and boy was hollywood going
to give it to them i think you've got
some serious issues believe it or not
the 330 million dollar box office hit
was bested by a 522 million dollar
taking for the 2004 sequel meet the
[ __ ] but then little [ __ ] missed
its shot when it arrived in 2010. yes
the film did technically earn 310
million dollars but there's nothing
hollywood likes less in a franchise than
a downward trajectory and the
inexplicably expensive 100 million
dollar price tag didn't help the reviews
were also abysmal and little [ __ ]
became one of the most loathed movies of
the year amassing an embarrassing nine
percent on rotten tomatoes wisely
universal was content to stop the
[ __ ] at three movies
from much of the 80s and into the 90s
the police academy movies seemed harder
to kill than jason voorhees
six films were made between 1984 and
1989 and even roger ebert stuck up for
their existence comparing the franchise
to the bowery boys and abbott and
costello as long as they kept making
money these films kept on coming back
the original film had made 81 million
dollars against a relatively tiny 4.5
million dollar budget police academy 2
their first assignment took in 55.3
million
police academy 3 back in training earned
43 million dollars and so on the pot of
gold was clearly shrinking but as long
as the films were made cheaply they
remained profitable that is until the
seventh film police academy mission to
moscow flopped hard bad luck seemed to
finally catch up with the dim-witted
cadets as the film had a final box
office hall of 126
247
or roughly one percent of its production
budget while critics had gone relatively
easy on the original police academy they
didn't hold back expressing their
distaste for the sequels movies four
through seven all racked up a perfect
zero percent on rotten tomatoes police
academy mission to moscow bombed hard
with audiences and critics alike so hard
that it finally killed an unkillable
franchise
the blade films had everything going for
them years of comic stories to draw from
wesley snipes in his prime and plenty of
kung fu vampire action all the
ingredients were there to keep the
sequel train running but then came blade
trinity the third installment of the
franchise received middling reviews and
disappointing grosses the end result of
an epic collapse that had begun to
unravel even as the cameras were rolling
snipes reportedly engaged in all sorts
of eccentric behavior behind the scenes
including trying to strangle the
director among other things walk by his
trailer and this
wall of of pot stench would just be like
whoa and kind of push you to the side
snipes was so unhappy after the release
of trinity that he ended up suing the
studio while the character is set to
live on in the marvel cinematic universe
blade trinity very much ended snipe
stays as the day walker
it sounds like a hollywood bingo card
reboot a title with ip recognition cast
it with one of the biggest movie stars
on the planet and use it to launch a
shared universe what could possibly go
wrong as it turns out everything hoping
to replicate the success of the mcu
universal announced in 2014 that
filmmakers alex kurtzman and chris
morgan would oversee a series of reboots
of the classic monster movies that had
launched the studio in the 1930s
christened the dark universe universal
very publicly revealed plans for a 2019
bride of frankenstein movie followed by
a new take on frankenstein starring
javier bardem as the monster an
invisible man movie with johnny depp and
a version of dr jekyll and mr hyde
featuring russell crowe in case you
haven't noticed none of these films ever
saw the light of day tom cruise's reboot
of the mummy is to blame for that
audiences had fond associations with the
beloved brendan fraser movies that had
signed off just a decade prior and cruz
still seemed like a box office sure
thing nevertheless the mummy flopped in
every way earning a terrible 16 on
rotten tomatoes and a disappointing 80
million dollars at the domestic box
office in the wake of the failure
kurtzman and morgan abandoned the
franchise followed shortly thereafter by
universal the dark universe had gone out
not with a bang but a whimper
[Music]